[Music]
i
care deeply about my work
and being the founder of a mental health
care company means i value my own mental
health well enough to know i can't
always be working
frankly that was pretty hard when i was
forced to work from home every single
day
and so
one of the
lessons of this past year and a half is
like i need to find ways to separate
work and home
and
you know a year ago even six months ago
that meant having to keep my laptop in a
very separate room and not permitting
technology in my bedroom
today
that means
adding to my calendar things like stop
working at 7 pm and which is i think a
lot earlier than most founders would
stop working i'm not excellent at it but
i try
i think something that is very difficult
to do as a founder is to separate your
identity from your company and
i know that if i don't build milestones
or forced mechanisms for me to ask
myself that i will get the two confused
so pretty early on at real i built in
quarterly check-ins with myself and only
with myself and had identified like what
are the questions i want to be asking
myself every three months and that
includes
am i the right person to be running this
company that includes am i happy doing
this does this make me feel fulfilled
and what do i need to whether it's you
know
employees to hire to take on things that
are on my plate or frankly space away
from work
building out that routine and
identifying those questions before
i was in the thick of real has been so
valuable for me because it really has
allowed me to
it's really just regrounded myself in a
ariella pre-reel and
given me the space to breathe the
permission to see a world outside of
real that's just hard to do
when your family and company certainly
heard me are doing it in a pandemic and
i recommend for all founders to really
build that into their schedules on a
routine basis and to do it separate of
anyone else because it's so hard to not
feel biased by employees advisors
investors you really need you need to
remember like you're forming a
relationship with yourself here right
this isn't about other people this is
like how do you want to live your life
and
i make it a point to ask myself that
regularly for me being productive means
that
i need time to rest you know a lot of
entrepreneurs and founders don't talk
about resting and sleeping
so for me i have a ritual of keeping a
period of a day to myself and family
and that helps recharge me to allow me
to be more productive in a day so i
think setting constraints is really
healthy
and made me
force me to be more efficient i
have a software background i studied
computer science at san diego state and
i think that using software and
automating a lot of the things that we
do so i have like a bunch of like zaps
set up in zapier so that i can automate
things like people
looking at like decks and and things
like that just like having more
information available
and not having to manually do it has
been really important
in terms of my routine
i feel like
i think i could do uh more around like
creating time for myself in the morning
that's that's like really important to
me having time to read a book and have
my morning cup of coffee and then jump
into my inbox and i also
love to write so like carving out time
for that has been really important i'm
i'm noodling on what book two could be
so i'm excited for that i i think like
one of the
hacks is always
like pausing
and taking a moment to like appreciate
what's going on and tell myself like you
have enough time
there there's no scarcity of time even
if it feels really overwhelming uh kind
of going through like are you hungry did
you sleep well did you exercise you know
did you drink water all these like basic
things that you can tend to forget about
but are very important for
anything else that you're doing so
so what helps me is something we do at
helena we work on two-week sprints which
helps with productivity because it gives
us short achievable milestones and i
think
when you have such a big vision for how
you want to
change food and nutrition which is what
we're trying to do you can't try to see
the big picture every single day and you
have to have bite-sized pieces to get
there and so that's been really helping
me in productivity is knowing that we're
not going to get the final answer right
now but we can chip away at it and get
there slowly with our two-week sprint so
that's uh
the mental model that i use uh small
tasks to get to the big finish when it
comes to technology that i use in my
day-to-day life
i keep it pretty simple actually i use
sleep cycle which is an app that tracks
my sleep and helps me just be more aware
of when i'm not getting the amount of
quality sleep i need because i think
that at the end of the day sleep is at
the core of anyone's productivity and
then i live and die by my calendar every
single thing that i do is color coded
and documented and i'm able to prepare
well in advance for any given meeting
that i have with a lot of detail when it
comes to more fun technology um the way
that i keep in touch with some of my
friends is frankly the instagram because
i've got friends i've i grew up all in
many different countries and so i've got
friends all over the world and i found
that given how busy i am running the
company it's hard to keep track of
everyone so it's one way for me to keep
tabs on people that i love i was
extremely unhealthy in the um
in the past few years i'm actually
starting to work out which has been a
big positive there's two types of things
that i have to accomplish today there's
things that drain my energy and things
that replenish it
and i try to balance that if i do too
much of the things that drain my energy
it can tend to be very exhausting and i
can tell you like when i used to do the
regulatory things i was constantly
exhausted because that's all that we had
to do for you know two years and that
was very energy training because reading
law writing law all these different
things now i try to balance that you
know to maybe like doing some regulatory
stuff it's a bit more energy draining um
to
but you know maybe talking to some team
members which is a little bit more
replenishing you know catching up with
some of our execs or other uh members of
the team and you know really finding
that balance is i think one of the best
ways of managing it
you know something i'm working on every
day in therapy i'm constantly thinking
i'm like this week
i don't need to go to therapy and then
right before i'm like oh my god my
therapist couldn't get here sooner
enough like i'm i would be lying if i
said i had it figured out i think
there's a misconception around
podcasting that's like oh just once a
week throw it out seven days a week i'm
working on the podcast and it's
consuming so i think for me my struggle
has been trying to find
work life balance my boyfriend is like
do you remember who i am and some days
i'm like no
daddy gang over everything so like i
would say i'm a workaholic and i am
really trying to
learn the balance so i actually this is
like so random i don't know if anyone
can relate to this but i just started
doing this thing where i find myself so
in work mode some days and then i'm like
rushing off to a dinner and i'm not the
best version of myself because i'm still
in work mode so i've allotted at least
one hour of time before i know i have to
go to something social because if you're
in work mode and then you have to go be
social or like go talk to your
mother-in-law or whoever i'm not married
why did i just say that um do you know
what i'm saying you need that time to
like switch hats almost so i've been
doing that and i find that i'm much more
pleasant
and able to converse and have a good
time in public settings now so i think
it's just like knowing that if you are
obsessed with your work you need to find
time to switch out of that role because
i think it can become addicting
especially with my career like i see
direct numbers and it's hard to walk
away from it also social media never
turns off and i think that's something
that creators are probably really
struggling with managing how do i
put it down
and detach for a minute but it's it's
making me money it's how my how all of
my listeners are waiting to hear from me
on the next thing like i could be doing
more more more so i think i've also
learned like more sometimes is shutting
off for a minute because then i'm going
to come back more refreshed and i'll
actually be giving them quality over
quantity
you